[Music]
hello and welcome to cross thought where
all things are considered I'm Peter
LaBelle Trump administration's attempts
to impose regime change on Venezuela
appeared to be faltering the
self-proclaimed interim president Juan
why though hasn't gained much traction
this may this may explain the
administration's escalating rhetoric
after all we are told the military
option is still on the table
[Music]
crosswalking Venezuela I'm joined by my
guest on the bar in New York
he's an anti-war activist and host of a
daily radio program in Geneva we have
Alfred disease he is a professor of law
at Geneva school of diplomacy and a
former UN independent expert on the
promotion of democratic and equitable
international order and in Ottawa we
cross to Isaac no Hans savatthi he is a
Venezuelan Canadian professor at the
University of Ottawa
all right gentlemen crosstalk rules in
effect that means he can jump in any
time you want and I always appreciate it
let me go to alfred first and in geneva
and congratulate him on his report that
he presented to the United Nations so
that was very enlightening I wish more
people would read it particularly in the
media and maybe in the American
political class Alfred
why does the United States feel it is
incumbent upon itself to fix the
problems of Venezuela no one denies
Venezuela has a lot of problems but why
should an outside power like the United
States that has a very checkered if and
I'm being very polite here checkered
history in meddling in Latin America so
I mean why is the Trump administration
and of all people Elliott Abrams
appointed to fix Venezuela well you know
Stephen kenter's book overthrow and
William blood blooms book killing hope
it is an American tradition to tell
Latin America to apply what we call the
Monroe Doctrine and we have a long
history Bay of Pigs and the iran-contra
affair Nicaragua Panama Grenada Haiti
etc we've been changing governments all
the time participating in the coup
against Celaya in on Dora so this is
nothing new I mean the United States is
a hegemon and does like to deal with
Latin America as colonies of course
Venezuela is after all an incredibly
rich country with the largest oil
reserves with enormous gold
reserves and bauxite reserves and coltan
reserves so it's a bonanza so Alfred
Alfred so it's so it's just an acid
plain let me go to Isaac here in Ottawa
I think is this it's very open unlike
you know other a force regime change in
the last two decades or so this
administration is very open that it
really wants the overthrow the
government impose its own guy somebody
that was hardly known even within the
country how do you think this forced
imposed regime change is going because
over the weekend it looked like a
it looked like a farce over the weekend
go ahead in Ottawa yeah I feel er well
this is not about the u.s. trying to
pull something this is about the
Venezuelan society saying enough is
enough enough is enough of a violent
regime enough is enough of a corrupt
regime enough is enough of
hyperinflation and now it is enough for
shortages enough is enough you have a
huge majority of Venezuelan saying
that's it we won't change
and we won't change if possible
peacefully we won't change in order to
have a free election and we won't change
because these people this regime cannot
last any more any longer that's it and
what is happening here is that you have
actually I think Alfred is somewhat miss
read miss reading the situation because
what is happening here you have not only
the US you have most of Latin American
countries you have Canada saying we
won't change the only difference what
right is but right is Canada have to say
about the faded Venezuela let me I don't
know you are you now we have to hegemon
it's okay dawn I mean I want free equal
time for everyone I told that before we
started the recording here let's go to
Don right now Don how is this a regime
change playing out because it seems to
me because of the fiasco over the
weekend on the bridge which was filmed
many people and it was quite obvious who
incited the violence there but then you
have within the same news cycle the
rhetoric is increased too you know they
always say that you know all options are
on the table here is this something that
do you do you think should happen could
happen certainly it shouldn't and why
should they listen to someone that is
under the Constitution of Venezuela is
and nobody still okay you know it does
Trump wanna risk his reelection
fortunes on on another failed regime
change expedition that we saw all
through the Middle East for the last two
decades go ahead Don well I'll go into
the details of this later but there are
billions of assets of Venezuela's that
are in litigation in the US courts with
a variety of multinational corporations
attempting to seize them and having the
u.s. recognize someone under their
control as president means that he can
walk into the court basically and
stipulate to whatever the other side
wants and release those assets to these
multinational corporations I'll get to
that more later I want to speak about
though the rhetoric with because we have
Marco Rubio holding up a picture of a
murdered Gaddafi if you think about it
Libya played pretty much the same role
in Africa that Venezuela was played in
Latin America for the last 20 years
helping to organize it helping to fund
its own independence and build you know
mutual defense of their sovereignty
standing up together etc and the Gaddafi
that was his crime but what Gaddafi did
when he took office took power and 69
was taking one of the poorest countries
in the world and left it a middle class
country where everyone there on their
own homes people there were comfortable
free education free health care etc
those are not people that go out into
the street and yet we see a picture of
him held up by Rubio as the threat to
Maduro now what what Rubio needs to know
is that there are also people that are
like him greedy little money-grubbing
people who go after other people's
assets to steal them and there are
photographs of their fate also the
picture of Mussolini I think is
something that someone
okay okay I think Marco Rubio really
embarrassed himself with that but that
embarrassment comes because of hubris
here let me go back to to Geneva Alfred
let's talk about the opposition here is
it still as fractures as it was before
because we had Isaac talk about
elections well it seems that the
opposition is boycotting any kind of
dialogue the government is asked for it
repeatedly with and met with silence
here and in the last election they
boycotted it so I mean what kind of
democratic credentials does the
opposition have if they don't want to
engage in talks or even participate in
an election go ahead in Geneva not very
believable when I was in Venezuela in
November December 2017 I spoke with
members of the National Assembly of the
opposition of Fela cameras the Chamber
of Commerce etc and somehow are feeling
that they have their conception of what
Venezuela is supposed to be and that
socialism is simply not part of it and
therefore they're not interested in
genuine dialogue as you know the former
Spanish Prime Minister Jose Luis a
Pharaoh conducted for two years years
yep
a negotiation face to face of the
opposition together with the government
and there were three ambassadors
supporting the opposition three
ambassadors of Latin America supporting
the government in any event on the 6th
of February 2018 there was a reasonable
compromise I published the agreement in
my report to the UN Human Rights Council
and what happened is that the phone rang
and the Julio Cortez gets the order no
fear of me so don't sign so he didn't
sign so I have feeling also the monthly
email mechanism proposed by me
Chico and Uruguay although it's a lovely
idea and I very much believe in
mediation it takes two to tango
oh it takes two to tango exactly here
let me I want to go back to Isaac here
because it's two against one and I want
to be fair here I I say cancer
Venezuelan yourself I mean would you
like to see an american-led military
intervention into your country go ahead
and uh no what I would like to see is a
peaceful transition but unfortunately we
have a regime that is not ready to
accept that we have a criminal regime
Venezuela what you are describing as a
socialist revolution this is this is not
the real thing what we have here is
narco Journal of trafficking with drugs
we have people trafficking with gold in
the South of Venezuela where you talk
about this all a saddam was talking
about eat all these assets and all these
issues that the venezuelan companies
such as paradiso have in the US it's
because chavez decided to confiscate
these these assets that's the problem i
secretly all due respect this interim
president Lula he wants to confiscate it
I mean is it a thief stealing from the
thief I mean that's its logic of this go
ahead I say keep going keep going
I mean destroy the visa
I mean Chavistas including Rafael
Ramirez
they destroyed by the visa that's why we
went from 3.5 million barrels per day
before Chavez to a situation now that
very lucrative Asia produces barely 1.2
meter barrels per day that was a drop of
oil price as well wasn't it yes exactly
the case of Russia that's not the case
of Saudi Arabia is not even the case of
the US I mean come on I know it's called
the global price drop
everybody was whele was heard the most
night what a guy would argue okay all
right gentlemen I'm good we have to go
to a short break and after that short
break we'll continue our discussion on
Venezuela stay with our team welcome
back to crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaValle to remind
you we're discussing Venezuela
[Music]
okay let me go back to Don in in New
York Don knows me very well and of
course my viewers do and I'm a very
conservative person I'm not a very big
friend of socialism as it has been
practiced in the world everyone knows
that
having said that Don and I'm not being
an apologist of Chavez but I think it's
pretty clear to say that a lot of people
were enfranchised in every single
possible way in Venezuela
I mean before Chavez the literacy rate
was low and now it's almost universal I
am NOT praising Chavez I'm praising
those programs all right so it seems to
me that there's millions and millions of
in his Whelan's that are invested in a
future that was being built under a
socialist government the socialist
government has made some very big big
mistakes and I always look at corruption
okay however my point is here is that
you have a population that is vested in
a future for Venezuela when they didn't
have that opportunity before go ahead
done yeah beginning with living in doors
since Chavez there's been two and a half
million two and a half million
apartments built for people who before
had to live in hovels that's in a
country of about 25 million people
that's a huge accomplishment under the
conditions that we just heard described
in terms of oil production which by the
way certainly the US sanctions that have
been imposed on Venezuela I've had an
impact as well as the litigation trying
to tie up the resources of Venezuela in
the US courts like citko have had an
impact on Venezuela was entire oil
industry but there are people who were
materially invested because their lives
are much better than they were before
and they comprise a little better than
half on Election Day they comprise
between forty and fifty five percent
depending on the election over the last
you know period since 1998 so you have
people who have an opinion about this
who feel very strongly I would just say
also when you have aerial views
the competing rallies go on in Venezuela
right now you have a good idea about
that because you have a million people
that show up for Maduro and tens of
thousands that show up for the
opposition okay I see cause I see eyes
ignitions are on the ground okay to give
the other prisoner to give the other
position I will introduce the question
here
Isaac reflect upon what you have heard
and are you for have you been a
supporter of these sanctions against
your country and do you support new
sanctions because it doesn't seem I
haven't finished my question it doesn't
seem to have had much impact on the
elites because well sanctions rarely do
go ahead Isaac and either first of all
the sanctions I mean this is these are
started actually a sanctions targeting
particular officials corrupt and violent
and violators of human rights that's
starting like that now they are focusing
on Sydenham addressed why because they
want these assets to be transferred to
the legitimate government of one way
though in order to benefit the people I
mean that's the first thing I'm talking
about the sanctions if you want to talk
about the sanctions and the effect on
people you don't have my mom 87 years
old living in Caracas she was in the
hospital last week and she had to take
an antibiotic for an infection and she
couldn't find the antibiotic and she
asked someone living abroad I'm gonna
tell you another thing we have power
shortages in Caracas every day my sister
who lives in downtown Caracas has power
shortages every day and these lack of
medication and these well that's because
but is that because of sanctions is that
because of sanctions nothing to do this
is because we have a failed day we fail
I see I see I see I see now I see how
I'd given you more than that Isaac be
fair I warned everyone before the
recording please don't talk over people
you were given your time slot Alfred you
were you raised your hand like a good
like a schoolboy wanting to inject
something go
you and you're a gentleman with the
bowtie I can't resist go ahead Alfred
well Peter when I went to Ennis whele I
thought like I said I thought you know
socialism is a failed model and it's all
medoras fault
now I spent an enormous time studying
the figures studying for instance the
book by Pasqualina cul co la mano vasily
del mercado studying articles that I
read in the Lamont diplomatic articles
by marca vice broad by Miguel tinker
Salas owes written a couple of very
clever books on Venezuela and I am
persuaded today that obviously in
socialism there too many ideologues are
not enough technocrats and you knew need
technocrats but the real crisis is a
direct result of the economic war and
the economic war did not start yesterday
the economic war started in 1999 there's
been 20 years economic war there's been
financial blockade and for instance when
the government has tried to buy insulin
you've had transactions stopped by the
banks because they will not transfer the
seven and a half million dollars
necessary to purchase insulin or to
purchase antiretroviral drugs back in
November set in 2017 when I was there it
was a malaria outbreak in the Amazon
region Maduro wants to buy anti malaria
medicine from Colombia Colombia says no
he has to go and buy it in India and
flow it in so the question is here the
cause of the crime okay the cause of
okay Alfred Alfred because of your good
behavior Isaac has raised his hand and
he would like to jump in Isaac would you
like to respond to what Alfred said you
cannot lie to people first I mean at
first I think the problem here is that
we have a failed state unable to provide
basic things to people and
won't talk about these colors writing
whatever about Venezuela I'm talking
about my family there man I'm not
talking about structions about data or
statistics I'm talking about the real
life of people when you have almost 4
million Venezuelan fleeing the country
do you think that they want to do that
because they like to leave Venezuela
they want to have all the hardships you
know going to Colombia Brazil even
Argentina no it's because they are
little situation but but I think but I
think you know what there's one way to
kind of result hang on Don everyone's
raising their hand that's great I just
wanted to say something the Isaac then I
will go directly to down here that's why
we have elections okay and if the
opposition doesn't want to participate
in elections then then really then
you're saying that you're giving your
you're giving way all right and you've
given way and and that and that's what
you get is a result here and since the
opposition hardly can speak to itself
before all this and now they won't speak
to anyone for a negotiated end to this
and this is what the government has been
saying Don you've been very patient I
have to give fair time to everyone Don
go ahead very quickly first at the
beginning of this if socialism is such a
failed experiment what is China because
they consider themselves still a
socialist and the communist state with
Chinese characteristics you know I have
to say that it's important for people to
keep in mind this thing that has to do
with Venezuela's assets being minoo at
the dock in the in US courts and that
the whoever ends up being the president
recognized by the US courts as president
in Venezuela will be free to dispose of
these we're talking about 1.3 billion
dollars for Chris taluk Center national
/ gold mine contracts for example would
Philip you bring you bring up a very
good point but what if this white old
guy can't get back into Venezuela's he
just could have sit on all the well
the Venezuela and a plush palatial New
York apartment is they gonna run the
country there I mean my goodness is
amazing Alfred you want to Jordan would
he be the I mean he wouldn't he would be
a billionaire in exile maybe that's not
a bad option for him
Alfred going I want to get I want to get
if everyone fair time Alfred go ahead I
think we all agree that we want
genuinely to help the Venezuelan out
crisis how to do it
I think through mediation I think the
Montevideo mechanism is a good idea I
think Antonio Guterres proposal to offer
it is the United Nations good offices is
good Michelle Bachelet our High
Commissioner has been officially invited
to visit the country I think all of
these are good initiatives we have to
calm down and we have to go back to the
UN Charter that prohibits the threat of
and the use of force we have to go back
to the OAS Charter I read you article 19
of the OS OS charter that says no state
or group of states has the right to
intervene directly or indirectly for any
reason for whatever in the internal
affairs a state article 20 no state may
use or encourage the use of coercive
measures of an economic or political
character in order to force the soccer I
want to make sure everyone gets one more
word in before we end Isaac in Ottawa go
just briefly about the Charter of the
Organization of American States
that's why Cuba was expelled in 61
because they interfere in the Venezuelan
affairs
you know they fail by invaded through
mature cuto Beach Venezuela and they
failed with the guerrilla Venezuelan
drama and qu the democratically elected
president you know won't the okay let me
tell you another thing about fair
elections let me tell you another thing
about fair elections in May 2018 can you
have fair elections
you pan can be raised from the position
to run when you have candidates like
Leopoldo Lopez in in a reason when you
have Henrique Capriles
than to run wasn't elected to anything
he proclaimed himself as the president
he was a stand-in
all right you are he's a deputy is a
representative who was elected in in the
fair election that we had because the
opposition thought for dr. election why
though was elected as a member of the
Venezuelan Parliament and he was elected
the president of the Venezuelan
Parliament and according to the
Venezuelan Constitution when you don't
have all right do that that is that is
one interpretation and gentlemen we've
run out of time I want to thank my
guests in New York Geneva and in Ottawa
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at RT see you next time and
please remember crosstalk rules
you